but uh speaking of humility we've got a
story about Hunter Biden here the most
uh humble member of I guess we could say
our royal class in the United States at
this point especially when you look at
the way that they're treated I mean you
know effectively he's he's royalty
people it's one of the number one
critiques of uh monarchy and it's one of
the number one reasons people supported
democracy what happens if you're in a
monarchy and the King just has an
absolutely horrible family unit being
ruled by complete degenerates well yeah
Robin Hood that's not a what if I mean
that's literally what is happening to us
right now not even democracy plenty of
depravity in the history of the Roman
Empire right amen these guys they made
they filled up the history books with
some pretty sleazy moves but we've had
we yes we have our own royal family we
wouldn't want them to get all the glory
we would also want to destroy the
reputation of American people bull
exactly so we have Elites in this
country this is something Ian and I
talked about quite a while ago uh and
what I said is the way I Define elite is
someone who who will not pay any
consequence for their actions that's
basically how an elite is defined in a
system which is as corrupt as ours is
and when you're looking at somebody like
Hunter Biden and our next story which is
the fact that IRS whistleblowers
actually came out and not just one but
two of them and allege that there was
political interference and the hunter
Biden investigation talk about
information I didn't need exactly
although this is exactly what I was
saying earlier with the lab hypothesis
right there's just story after story
after story of the conspiracy theorists
being proven right information that we
were already well aware of I appreciate
these guys coming forward I agree that
this stuff has to come out and it's good
that they're talking about it but the
fact is nobody thought this was going to
be impartial or unbiased under the Obama
Administration the IRS was specifically
targeting conservative groups this has
been a biased Organization for a very
long time it didn't start with Hunter
Biden and if it did start with Hunter
Biden it was so blatant and obvious that
basically everyone in this country was
already in a position where they'd be
capable of hearing it without these
whistleblowers that said we're glad they
stepped forward they should be commended
and they should be thanked
the justice department in Delaware U.S
attorney's office went out of their way
to hamper an IRS investigation of Hunter
Biden's taxes by consistently slow
walking the case preventing enforcement
actions by the IRS and tipping off
actions related to the investigation to
Biden's attorneys in advance according
to a new whistleblower testimony
released Thursday by the house Ways and
Means Committee now just a show of hands
who in the room is surprised by this
cricket sound effect yeah exactly it's
weird when there's a story where the IRS
are the good guys like the IRS are like
we're just trying to do our job the the
people disobeying the IRS from inside of
the IRS were the good guys
but it's the justice department in
Delaware attorneys General's office that
are that are slow walking this
investigation they have been I mean
the mere fact that they never acted on
any of this stuff I mean
you know that's the dog that didn't bark
I mean it was obvious and I mean and
apparently everyone knew that that was a
private franchise of the Biden family I
mean this is not news to anyone
well and you look at the fact that Biden
Hunter Biden that is specifically failed
to pay about a million dollars in taxes
and I'm asking you as a lawyer if if I
you know a nice guy like me failed to
pay the government a million dollars
that I owed it do you think I would get
two misdemeanor charges I'd be able to
plead out of that I think you would get
two misdemeanor charges on every square
inch of your body uh and the felony
charges would be lodged in um other
parts of your body that would be less
visible
no okay that's a colorful way of
describing it let me ask what if you
were my lawyer
then you'd you wouldn't even get the two
all right perfect yeah maybe well maybe
that was Hunter's mistaken if you hire
you you would you would you would get a
Congressional Medal amount I mean I
think it's worth noting that he I'm
surprised Hunter didn't to be honest I
mean it's coming he hasn't gotten it
yeah there's no such thing as a law firm
anymore that works for both Democrats
and Republicans that's over
um so yeah we are I don't know if you
might have picked up on this harmony
Dylan thing but we are a republican
welfare is there really none there's
there's no impartial ones for all
practical purposes that's that's I mean
in the upper echelons I mean it might be
in local politics that is that it's
still more
you know unpolitical but is that just
since Trump got in Trump was the turning
point
yeah yeah I would say so sorry Hannah
okay I think it's worth noting that
these this whistleblower testimony was
pre-scheduled I'm assuming so they
always knew that they were going to
testify on the 22nd and earlier this
week is when Hunter Biden accepts his
plea deal and is like ah yes I did do
something wrong we're not going to talk
about it anymore uh that means they knew
this was coming that makes me think what
else is going to come out again I always
think anyone in these places positions
of power or privilege uh try to get in
front of the story so if Hunter accepted
the plea deal on what was it Monday
what other whistleblower testimony are
they trying to prevent from from moving
forward because his attorney
specifically said with this plea deal my
understanding is that the investigation
is closed like now we stopped any more
questions
it's true but it is interesting that his
attorney's position is now you stop
asking questions Hunter took the guilty
plea we're not going to talk about it
anymore and obviously I don't think most
of the American public agrees with that
uh We've referenced it a couple times
this idea of a a multi-tier justice
system in which Hunter Biden is allowed
to uh you know every report that I read
after he his plea came out was he is not
expected to serve jail time he's also
got this gun charge uh hanging over his
head that is punishable by up to 10
years in prison and he's a white man you
think he's going to get it yeah no
there's no expectation in her country
that he will go to jail and the fact
that all of us can look at each other
and say it's extremely unlikely that
Hunter Biden's gonna go to jail for
something that anyone else in this room
would be convicted and punished to the
full sex of the law is crazy how can uh
Joe Biden who's presenting himself as a
man of the people all the unions support
him middle class Joey calls himself for
himself ignore his way out of this his
son is not going to serve a sentence
that everyone else in this country would
have he played the nepotism card when
they asked him he's going to rub your
nose in it I love my son look at it as
the commander-in-chief of the military
when finding massive corruption with a
family member was it's my family member
you're the commander you have no choice
you have to put your family member in
prison like if they violate Authority
you do what's right for the country
that's why you have the role no amen
for anyone who would for anyone who
would argue that he should not allow for
Hunter to be locked up because that's
his son and he's in this position of
authority well you know what if your son
doesn't care for the boundaries that you
have to set as a leader enough to not
break the law and embarrass you
immensely when you're the president of
the United States then what do you owe
him lock him up now of course we know
what Hunter owes him and it's allegedly
10 but well I think it's worth noting
that Hunter didn't file taxes in 2017
and 2018. there is no way on Earth that
Joe Biden wasn't considering running for
the presidency at some point in the
years before that that means he knew
that he was potentially going to run
every person who's run for office goes
through uh intense scrutiny he couldn't
have looked at Hunter and be like did
you file your taxes that would be really
good for me if you did that well
Hunter's the smartest guy he knows
that's true which actually the thing is
that actually might be true Hunter might
be the smartest person Joe Biden knows
which is scary which is scary but I
think that might be true when you just
look at his Circle I think that Joe is
going through a state of mind right now
where he's like oh I I did this to
Hunter it's my fault for putting a
memberisma I'm gonna eat this one just
let him go he's not Joe Biden isn't
being punished not being punished so no
one's being punished for this and again
this is not the way anyone else would be
treated and I think there is no way
voters can look at the bidens and say
they are of the people they are not do
by the way I mentioned this earlier but
do you remember when he claimed that
people called him middle class Joe they
didn't mean it was a compliment man no
one ever called you that ever first of
all no one in American politics is going
oh look at the purse in the middle class
can relate to Let's laugh at them that's
not how this country works okay people
who hate the middle class still pretend
to love it while denigrating it
stripping all of its wealth away and
insulting its values no one ever called
Joe Biden middle class jail but you were
going to make a point and I so rudely
interrupted
no I don't think so I think I might have
I I do have this ability to make a face
that looks like I'm about to make a
point but uh if I was I would I don't
remember what it was no actually the
point was I knew it I have to come up
with a point now right he's got a
filibuster till he has a point point was
it was never any concern whatsoever on
his part whether or not he filed the
taxes because he knew that no he's never
been held accountable for anything and
he will not be held accountable for
anything because they have the system
absolutely
right stacked right what if this was
Donald Trump Jr what would we hear from
the media what would you hear from from
Congress what we hear from the executive
branch there's no way he wouldn't do
prison time we were being told like Adam
Schiff was saying that he had
information about Trump Jr and that he
was going to be thrown in prison and we
were hearing all of this nonsense from
everyone meeting about how the walls
were closing in they were closing in on
Donald Trump and they were closing in on
his family and of course what we ended
up finding with the investigation with
the Durham report was once again
something that we all knew which was
that the Deep state was politically
motivated and they were attempting a
soft goo against a sitting president so
when somebody who was anti-establishment
ends up attaining the highest office in
the country in an unbelievable and
unprecedented feat by being elected
president as an outsider and then the
Deep state does everything they can to
subvert the Democratic process and
unseat that person and everyone in the
media repeats a narrative which we all
know was a total farce to the point
where they convinced the American people
to believe things that are factually
untrue to the point
of Democrats intuitively to the point
where 60 percent of Democrats said in a
Yugo survey that the 2016 election was
tampered with by Russians in the sense
that they were literally retaliing vote
totals now no one in the media openly
said this they just very strongly
implied it for several years so that's
the treatment that you get when you're
an outsider trying to enter into the
establishment when you are in The
Establishment you can do whatever you
want and you will not pay any price and
if you do it'll be a slap on the wrist
so they can say see we're in partial
Hunter Biden did end up catching charges
he was prosecuted in a court of law
because we gave him two misdemeanors for
something you'd be spending decades in
jail for had you done it yeah
I mean we're done that's everything
that's all of it I think you probably
speak to this better than I can but with
a plea deal both sides come to an
agreement someone says this is what
we're willing to offer you and that
means the US government was like Hunter
we're willing to offer you no jail time
for this like that's bizarre to me this
seems so crazy it's not unexpected he is
the president's son on the other hand I
just think voters should remember this
as they go towards November 2024.
absolutely agreed absolutely agreed and
uh very very very few voters will be
swayed by it yeah that's true I don't
know about that because it was something
like 10 of Voters according to a poll
published by the Washington examiner
said had the hunter Biden laptop story
not been covered up they wouldn't have
voted for Joe I just think it's what do
you think some people will care yeah
that's actually very few though at the
ten percent of them people who voted
Democrat I believe I understand that
it's like seven to ten I I want to
double check on that and it might be
that that might have made a difference
in a couple of Swing States but at the
end of the day what we are saying is at
90 percent
Or democrats would have Shrugged their
shoulders yeah oh absolutely we don't
shrug their shoulders as many times as
possible you just need to wake enough
people up referencing polls is risky
because you got to find out how many
people it might be that it was like a
thousand people were asked and it was
ten percent of a thousand people said
and the question might have been asked
like had you known that Hunter Biden's
laptop something something where as
opposed to if they just seen the laptop
two weeks ago it wouldn't really have
but when they're looking at the piece of
paper with the question on it they're
like yes I just think under biting
cumulative that's fair but I do think I
agree with you that polls were imperfect
but I think when we have the information
it's important to do something with it
yeah I was gonna say I think just
cumulatively we should look at Hunter
Biden we should talk about Navy his his
daughter who is also he's ignoring like
I think we should all look at everything
Hunter Biden does and say this is the
child that Joe Biden raised yeah maybe
it's not enough to persuade every voter
but I think but it's but the real story
though is notwithstanding the characters
serious character flows of Hunter Biden
and many great families have had
seriously depraved children
and a great deal of wealth can have that
effectively families and especially when
it's
wealth generated by corruption yeah but
the real story going back to our theme
is
this is what Elites can get away with
yes it's what Elites can get away with
and I'll also add this
it's not just that Hunter Biden was
raised in an extremely wealthy family
it's he was raised in an extremely
wealthy family and his father is a
coward and a phony his dad also probably
wasn't around very much I mean if he
worked for 40 50 years in in Congress
he's been Congress since the 70s right
that's uh that's a long time to be
spending 28 days a month away from your
family he's from Delaware he took the
train home every night yeah he took the
trailer
yeah that's what he claimed that's good
they called the middle class Joe and he
took the train home every night and he
fought corn
he gave himself a nickname so they
called me man they didn't mean it as a
compliment man it's like okay well let
me tell you something Joe this is what
happens to you by the way when when
Hunter is the smartest person who you
know Biden was in India alongside the
Indian Prime Minister and he he raised
his hand to his heart because uh
Washington he was oh I'm so sorry he was
in Washington but they were that you're
absolutely correct yes you have the
presidential seal right there points
you're never coming back on this show
here's here's well maybe Hunter's the
smartest guy I know at this point I'm
just completely uh completely crashed it
goes okay I want to try again all right
so we're just gonna we're gonna start
again and we're gonna edit this okay all
right no one's ever gonna see this
happen all right so this is what happens
when Hunter Biden is the smartest person
you know Joe Biden was alongside the
Indian Prime Minister he raised his hand
to his heart because he expected that
they were going to play the U.S national
anthem and they didn't they played the
Indian national anthem of course and Joe
Budden
it's hard to lower
when he realized
oh man look at that what a champ that's
why video cameras are cool yeah I think
I think this is gonna be the thing
that's going to make people uh realize
that Joe is not who they think he is I
think it's seeing more and more gas but
I mean there's it's like a gaff a day
it's multiple games per day we see like
one up dude yeah remember when he said
he broke his leg because he was grabbing
his dog's tail getting out of the shower
and it's like I don't I don't know dude
this man got elected and then I believe
it was just right after he was
inaugurated he told us he broke his leg
because he tried to grab his dog's towel
while he was getting out of the shower
and his foot I just I like to imagine
most Americans we're we're looking at
that and going oh my goodness what have
we done but I actually don't think so I
I think a lot of them were thinking like
thank God Trump's not in office no he
might have broke his leg when he tried
to grab his dog's tail getting out of
the shower it's like it would be worse
if Trump was in office exactly that's a
lot of the thoughts right now is very
scary it is very Ron is a very Grim face
yeah tell me more
how much do you love Joe Biden on a
scale from one to a hundred
I know love is a vague word but I have
no use for Joe Biden and then one to 100
is too granular do you think that
there's like one value ten he gets he
gets a two there there have been worse
tyrants than Joe Byron Joe Joe Byron I
like to talk about that doesn't even
make it worse do it you know he's so
mediocre
he's a wannabe dictator he's a mediocre
dictator I think you should be a proper
dictator well that's the thing though is
that he's a dictator who you can buy
okay as opposed to those dictators who
you can't even buy because it's a fair
point the dictators who like own the
people with money as opposed to the ones
who are owned by the people with money
very good point I get this Vibe and I
don't have a reference that he's like
functioning as a dictator but doesn't no
doesn't realize it yeah I don't know I
think he realized anything he's got
remember when he said he was losing his
patience with us I'm losing my patience
man like what do you mean your patience
your memory extends five seconds into
the past there's no it's not possible
for you to lose your patience but he's
been a senator not just a mere member of
Congress which is
only a couple of clicks above being a
Milkman okay it's below being a Milkmen
are useful they bring us a product that
we use they're good people
speaking of which I just spilled water
on this keyboard flip it upside down
that's the best thing I'm so angry but
did you ever see Tim in a million years
Tim would have never spilled water can
you believe live on the show he actually
has it he actually has it no no no why
Tim lost his voice
Sheamus gets a big ego and he thinks I
can do this show Tim you don't see them
he's like you should have done this you
should oh not only that I saw Jack
lastly it's worse than that I got him
sick actually I coughed in his dream
house I said I said I'm gonna be the
host the next time
of water on the keyboard you know he
he's he's a king he comes in he owes he
absolutely has the moves Sheamus was
thinking obviously anyone could do this
I said I said it's Child's Play turns
out it's harder than he thinks I don't
know I didn't I mean I think we are
there we're I'm gonna return to the
point here because we can talk about
endless number of Joe Biden gaffs my
personal favorite was when he was in
Ireland and said I don't want to go home
statement did he say I don't want to go
home when he was in Ireland he also said
he's not Irish because none of his
relatives are drunk or in jail well it's
rough uh and if you're black you if you
don't vote for Joe Biden you're not
black there's rough stuff coming out is
this enough though we're sort of
returning back to the same point will
voters look at this guy and say we can't
keep going he is unpopular there were
polls that indicated a majority of
Democrats felt he was too old to run
again nonetheless the Democratic party
seems to think that they're gonna you
know uh pick him as their nominee at
what point do we look at him and say
nothing you can do matters because you
are going to have the establishment
behind you yeah I'm in that point right
now but I also think hating someone is
not the way to make a better world like
a lot of what got us here was trumped
Arrangement people that couldn't stand
Trump they'll vote for anything else so
if people hate Biden that much they'll
vote for anything else could be even
worse it could be exponentially worse
and that's why the reason that I say
he's not a tyrant is you know and before
you before you had your confidence
problem over here uh it was that
he's not a dictator he is he he is he's
a crook
and he enjoys having power so that he
can enrich himself he's been a senator
for a generation then he was vice
president which is a job where you get
lots of quirks quirks quirks is
interesting
lots of perks and and queer perks that's
what I was thinking it is pride month
yeah a lot but the point is he's used to
being the boss he's used to being the
the man and and he's and he's risen into
seniority in the Senate he's you know he
therefore he is impatient
he is short with people he's not bright
so therefore he uses Authority as a
proxy for
the ability to
convince people and and if you you know
we all should take a look everyone
before you go to bed tonight
look at Joe a video of Joe Biden from
the 70s or 80s this was a very very
articulate man not brilliant and not
well spoken as such but the point is he
okay so if he's articulate he's well
spoken but he he had the tools to do the
job and then he ran out of gas but what
he became was a useful we have a word in
Yiddish a Golem he became a a zombie an
effective zombie in whom you know a new
SD card could be placed every morning
with that day's you know where to stand
and he has all those you know many years
of of authority but when do you think he
ran out of gas I'm just curious during
the Obama Administration you know I
think you you could see one man coming
in a much less of a man coming out yeah
he used to talk really fast and sharp
even in like 2006 in those debates with
Obama and Hillary Clinton man he was I
mean I didn't like him he was on chopped
liver out of out of Paul Ryan yeah yeah
but then he returned to the camera
because the way he Ryan was terrible
and Biden he they had and by the way
whoever coaches the Democrats on
uh on debates
years ago they have a thing about
smiling
a really obnoxious thing about smile and
I remember Biden looking into the camera
with these phony pearly whites yeah and
just smirk and boy he's been phony oh my
gosh but but Ryan was helpless Ryan was
like a deer caught in the headlines you
don't think so yeah Biden Ryan uh well
look it's been a long time I mean this
was the 2012 cycle I was pretty young
still in high school six seven no he's
talking about Paul Ryan I remember
watching it and at the time I thought
that Ryan did better because I wasn't
really impressed by Joe Biden but that
also could have been my political bias
and the fact that I was 17 uh at the
time thanks for watching this clip from
the timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time